right to some developing news here at
home today the two people accused of
robbing and killing a 70 year old man
outside of his
own home are due in court this happened
sunday night in the southeast valley our
hector mejia is live in downtown las
vegas with an update on this case good
morning to you hector
hey there alex good morning and the
suspects each faced three felony charges
including murder
and rob were either accused of following
the victim home from a bar
and ambushing him in his own driveway 70
year old allen
bondulid was shot in the chest beaten
while he was on the ground
and left for dead outside of his home
sunday night the suspect's 36 year old
otis buchanan and 31 year old delena
smedley allegedly stole his wallet and
then took off
running this happened sunday night not
too far from tropicana and mount vista
neighbors are the ones who heard the
gunshots and called police
i don't feel any less safe i understand
the gravity of what happened
but at the same time you know you can't
live your life to
you know sheltered inside you know bad
things are going to happen unfortunately
i looked up court records this morning
and both suspects are being held with no
bail and they're due in court at nine
o'clock this morning if you know any
information
that might be useful for police they're
asking that you please give them a call
you can call crime stoppers and remain
anonymous reporting live
hector mejia 8 news now